hello everybody my name is mark blair
and welcome back to at dead of night
i'm on the third floor which is where
i'm supposed to be uh to find out more
about jimmy
and his wonderful upbringing
as really just a
just a swell kid i'm thinking actually
that might be pointing this way and then
down to the left yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
starting to get it now oh no no no no no
hello
oh no well that's loud
hi oh no
[Music]
okay
well rose finding lots of mana yeah you
know that's my nightmare too um
rosie there is it rose
rose
all right i get yeah okay okay okay i'll
go this way oh apparently i gotta go in
this room
oh god hey oh hey oh no oh no
oh no oh no
no you don't the thing is you don't
that's the funniest thing that's the
most hilarious thing actually is that
you don't see me a little bit of panic
there but yeah no
i don't like mannequins i think i've
said this before recently
i've said it many times throughout my
youtube career i just don't
like them they're the uncanny valley
doesn't do very well for me
oh hey bud what's up hugo
you go away
okay yeah yeah you go you go go you go
go go
all right yeah this is the smallest
floor so really there's not a lot of
space to get away from him
you're there is it rose roots is it
blues
okay so about all those mannequins full
of mannequins
terrible
i was terrible but then i realized
jimmy wasn't the one doing these things
[Music]
hmm
i see
i see interesting
like i said last time this is where all
the dissociative identity disorder
comes in okay so i don't okay
she's gone apparently so i just i'll cry
then
he can't get me when i'm scrying can he
probably not i'm probably fine
ah okay g what am i gonna find on g
and probably more hugo stuff are you
there dude
better not be there god
okay i think he's far away not 100 sure
it seems
vaguely distant now if i could just
remember how to get there
oh god damn it god damn you how the hell
[Music]
how are you supposed to know i waited at
everything
ah titty sprinkles
all right where am i now god damn
uh floor two i think is the red one no
floor one okay
well that's handy okay not the way of
the circus i do know that now
not that way this way
this way yes i don't know why he likes
to put me in 107 but at least it's not
too far away from the machine
and honestly that's quicker than
trying to sneak past him anyway it's
like my tax you know to talk with ghosts
i just need to get procedurally more and
more brain damage
so long as my brain gets blambaged i can
talk to more ghosts it's a
weird coincidence how that works out
jimmy's a real sneaky guy
is that his show does he call people up
on stage and just smash him in the head
with a bat
and the people in the front have their
their plastic sheets so they don't get
brain and blood splattered on them
it's a great show everyone thinks it's a
act but you know
poor people hilarious actually
[Music]
yeah it's normal
[Applause]
yep okay all right
hello oh no where's my compass did i
lose my compass too what happened to my
compass
oh my god i had a google doc open and
just writing started appeared on it
i was just like holy [ __ ] okay
um so i don't have a compass uh is that
normal
i have compass it just doesn't show
comfy here
oh now i show cumpy where was compe
before
oh so not that way interesting here
no but here's some it's just his comedy
routine
it's his sense of humor i'm sorry if
you've been offended
excuse me
all right well his sense of humor needs
some work apparently
wait where am i going here this here
heroes
is it rose is it rose why are you so
uncertain
i'm rose i saw you in the ballroom
the audience was booing and you were
apologizing what was happening
it wasn't jimmy on stage anymore it was
hugo punch his comedy character
hugo started insulting his audience
every night
he seemed to be enjoying it and one
night after the show
[Music]
did he hugo punch
this person all right uh do i need to
connect any of this
um who well he's done a few stupid
things before with
crossbows and bats and wait do you know
about the washington
washing line tied around a rolling pin
yeah what was that all
don't know about fine whatever um
yeah i've seen so much stuff i'm not
exactly sure what would
be oh the wedding did the wedding ring
belong to wasn't that yours
jimmy used to carry wire around
hmm interesting okay okay so
lost his temper and did something stupid
i
might not have the thing for that so i'm
going to go ahead and i'm going to scry
in the uh
i'm going to scry in the the the
turret why are you
maybe i do have what i need because i
definitely got to talk to her back there
but let me just try to see if i have
the thing yet which i may not i may need
to go up and go get it
why it was the wire
it was the wire okay so it was the wire
okay so now we're finally gonna figure
out what the hell this wire was for
because i don't think we ever got an
answer to that
unless we did about the uh electric
heater or something like that
i don't know we haven't really explored
this he's done the whole glass and the
sandwich trick hilarious he's done the
whole crossbow to the leg trick
really funny um is someone there we'll
just figure out the rest of it
later hey it's rose is it is it
rose yes i'm
rose okay what about this in the wire
when you said jimmy lost his temper and
did something stupid
is that connected to what you said about
the coil of
[Music]
jimmy locked her wire a room and tied
her up i didn't know what he was going
to do
i found her and let her go jimmy said it
was a joke
she didn't press charges but she told
the newspapers
maybe she should have pressed charges
maybe maybe she should have pressed
charges yeah
i think maybe it should have been a good
idea to press charges about that
okay well you know we're kind of seeing
that same joke
play out oh that's real
oh okay uh hello
uh oh
is this oh the phone the the
[ __ ] the fun phone how do i get to the
phone
how do i
oh
hello
oh hello
something's up
what's up what's up what's the deal
what's the deal guys what's the deal
what's happening
what's up guys hi
i thought it was a phone turns out it
was adorable i thought for a moment it
was a doorbell there but i was like oh
that must be a weird light switch but
turns out apparently not is it rice
is it rose
[Music]
so what about the old door people said
people were knocking on the door asking
questions
who were they
journalists they wanted jimmy
but jimmy wasn't in control it was hugo
punchier tied the woman up
jimmy couldn't control it anymore he was
depressed
he just wanted to leave everything
behind and go i supposed to make oh the
bags
the bags the bags the bags are the bags
i saw some suitcases in the chest who
did they belong to
ah interesting are these connected when
you said jimmy wanted to leave
everything behind and go is that
connected to what you said about the
suitcases maybe
could be ah damn it okay so it's gotta
be something else
in relation to the whole going away kind
of thing
um let me go scry just so i don't waste
too much time
and i will waste a lot of time
[Music]
i completely forgot about that i
completely forgot that there was a weird
letter that no one understood what it
was
and i was like oh yeah it must be jimmy
but i i didn't know
weird is it right right
roby bro rose bro rose
um letter letter letter letter write the
name right
goodbye
jimmy's not dead is he
when you said jimmy wanted to leave
everything behind and go
is that connected to the goodbye note
jimmy hated what he'd done he'd been
fighting hugo punch
all his life he was inside him
making him do all those bad things
jimmy didn't want to live anymore
[Music]
has jimmy been dead the whole time
maybe but i don't know i don't want to
leap to that conclusion yet but holy
[ __ ] if that
if that was the case oh
because you see other dead people around
here
and jimmy kind of appears here and there
oh no come on what no way what
no place your bets in the comments below
oh that sounds real good
oh yeah that sounds good oh yeah this
sounds good
oh yeah oh wait no behind
oh oh oh no
oh no oh no i don't like it
oh [ __ ] what do i do
what do i do what do i do i don't
remember which one was jimmy's room
don't have uh uh yeah yeah
so yeah i think you gotta go back and
get the keys every single time you die
it's jimmy dead
is jimmy dad is it rose
i saw you in a room upstairs it looked
like you'd find someone in the bathroom
what happened
[Music]
it was jimmy he tried to kill himself
that's why i had to tell him the truth
okay so he's not dead okay but
so i'm guessing this truth is
tied to uh this great hugo
hmm hair sightings and objects
okay i get you um
truth right truth is you know subjective
isn't it it's not but let's just go with
it
okay uh so the truth let me just cry
because
i don't know if um let me let me
deadbolt first
let me deadbolt let me death bolt this
okay good oh
the ring also symbolizes that
relationship with the great hugo where
you
were his assistant and then things
developed
i see i see i see i see i see i see i
see i see i see i see
is it rose is it rice is it
yes
okay so it's this and then the ring i
should have guessed that
i was on the right track i just didn't
think of the right eye tell jimmy the
truth
is that connected to the wedding ring
oh what better do the thing
wait okay wait okay let me okay what
about what about this and the great hugo
when you said things developed with hugo
is that connected to the wedding ring
yes we were
so i don't think i can pair this with
that you really gotta pair this with an
item
had to tell the truth so what about
now if it still says of the ring i'm
gonna i'm gonna throttle
someone i'm gonna throttle someone i
will throttle it
tell me the truth damn it tell me the
truth
305 huh okay 305 it is three or five it
is
three or five all right let's see if
he's waiting outside this door
yeah i've been talking to your mom what
of it
you there second floor is kind of big i
don't even know if you can make it here
i say with confidence
i'm waiting
sure seemed quiet okay
okay
i don't remember which way to go god
damn it
oh this way okay it's this way
okay
okay that's weird he wasn't there
interesting kind of a different flavor
i'm not too in love with it but whatever
i'm opening a new
new right there it was hey how are you
doing well too bad you're on that floor
and i'm on this floor
ke thunk cath uncles okay 305.
thankfully level 3 is not too
complicated 305.
305. this way i'm guessing
this way in a hurry what's this 302
it's probably down the other way
goddammit uh why is it so big
303 uh three or four three or five
right three or five
perfect okay easy enough
what do we got oh a baby toy hmm
interesting
all right baby toy it is uh you there
i'm guessing i'm just going to cry
because i probably got to go down and
talk to her again but i want to make
sure she hasn't moved
that happens okay i know the baby i know
the baby toy i know
okay whatever yeah i get it too okay
all right so i just gotta get past mr
smacks a lot
and uh hopefully he's not right here
okay i don't hear him
it's about as good a sign as i could
hope for
what was that
i'm gonna do the the trick of i'm gonna
call him past
this room and he's gonna go by i'm gonna
shout out to jimmy and he's not gonna go
in this room
hey
i'm gonna watch yeah yeah you pissed now
huh you pissed
now just go nicely past there he goes
there he goes okay
and now i'm uh go for it that was quick
too oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh god i hope i go
the right way oh god please let me go
the right way
holy [ __ ] here we go this is the right
way ah
i did it god damn it
[Music]
oh
well that didn't go well that went very
poorly actually
that went excessively poorly i didn't do
that
good at all ah
i'm dead i'm dead he's uh man i i cannot
believe
i don't know why i don't know which way
to
go in this goddamn game for some reason
it really screws with me
okay
good good i wonder if he just always
kills you if you go into the closet
because it really seems like he just
always kills you if you go in the closet
i swear
i swear on everything i'm gonna go the
right way
here we go one more time into the
thunderdome
here we go and then a left and then a go
and then uh immediately
oh my god it was no god damn it i didn't
mean because that was actually an
accident
that was actually a raw i didn't mean to
freaking
i legitimately did not want to go that
way
i wanted to go straight
i'm dead there's no way that i get away
from this a third time
[Music]
okay all right we're good god
damn everything i hate everything god i
could have just been beaned in the brain
taking the blame blambladge
holy [ __ ]
well blaine blemish is the least of my
concerns
you'd think he'd learn and i think he's
learned you know honestly i think at
this point he's definitely learned
[Music]
how's lucky number four
okay apparently that's fine you are not
seeing anything i'm going to the right
and then i'm going this way and then i'm
going this way and then i'm going
straight
and then i'm going this way and then i'm
going this way and then i'm going this
way and then i'm turning right and then
i'm calling the left and then you're not
right behind me and then i wait for the
lift and then i go on the left
and then i press two
all good easy actually
i don't know why everyone's stressed why
are you all stressed
it's really nothing when you're this
skilled
almost too easy all right let's get this
show on the road
hey any ghosts around
all right rosie there goddammit rose
that's where
baby rattle on rose rice rose
[Music]
who did the baby's rattle belong to hmm
when you said you had to tell jimmy the
truth does that have something to do
with the baby's rattle
all right well then i don't know what
the hell you want me to know about
anything i don't know i don't know
what you mean about anything to whatever
what you have i'll just cry
that's how i know what to do
[Music]
baby rattle the baby rattle so there
must be another connection with
something that she said or that i saw of
her
that the baby rattle goes to and then
then it goes deeper
from there
okay so jimmy had enough
[Music]
apologize to guest found out about that
okay what about this backstage
the mannequins it wouldn't have anything
to do with the mannequins
wait a minute
about that you said there was only one
thing you could give hugo
does that have something to do with the
baby's rattle
i thought having a child would solve
everything always does
i was wrong yeah
a baby does it
you already hear first folks a baby
solves absolutely
nothing okay so that's interesting is
there another piece of information that
i need
now after that piece of information oh
we are close to the end here we are
getting real close
i gotta go to ground floor again what in
the hell it's running me all over the
place
it's weird i guess ground floor it is
okay
weird i'm still wondering if
if mr jimmy's dead okay he sounds pretty
far i think i can at least get up a
couple
rooms and then call them and then run
okay i should be able to do it here and
then get down and then ground floor easy
peasy
hey [ __ ]
[Music]
okay here we go here we go here we go
here we go
[Applause]
a bad egg not me come on
yes i am correct i'm the best i'm the
greatest
i am the strongest i am the fastest i am
the most robust
the biggest of titty i am the best
no one can beat me thank you thank you
later nerd see you never or i'll see you
on the ground floor with this next plot
point
that i'm going to discover
anybody here
[Music]
hello
hello hello
hello here we go
uh
hello
well you know when in doubt go around
the corner i guess
what is happening
oh what if i call the elevator
oh
oh i'm going down too
well oh uh
basement store oh uh that's convenient
um
all uh i'm guessing i go to the basement
store then
right
i mean i got a key that says basement
store so i'm gonna go to the
basement store must be one of these
doors down here i guess
this one maybe that's the only wood one
i think
yep okay hello oh
well i hate it immediately so there's
that
um nothing
oh certified copy of an
entry pursuant to births okay james
alexander hall so jimmy hall
hugo hall okay
this makes sense statement stage [ __ ] i
thought that's a state magician
like oh school teacher also okay well
interesting fascinating
i mean this all i pretty much guess
early on
but i think this means that jimmy ain't
dead rose
was probably killed by
the great hugo not not so great in my
mind
but uh yeah
all right let's go scry in the kitchen i
gotta go in the kitchen look at the
mirror
so i can tell my future i probably gotta
go up into a room and
have one last conversation with the rose
i imagine
and then jimmy will return to normal
yeah i know the birth certificate i know
about that
oh do i need to go to two two three oh i
probably need to go two two three again
yeah yeah i need to go two two three
again okay i got it okay
okay so yeah i i just so happened to not
collect the right pieces of information
before i got to that location
okay and this is where the truth comes
out
the truth is revealed at this juncture
we will all know exactly what it is
that jimmy will discover from his own
mother
also where is the great hugo during all
this
because that would have been a while ago
you know considering he's jimmy's like
almost an adult now
or then in the storytelling of
now and then whatever all right i hope
he's not
around
okay all right hey rules
is anyone there anyone there
i can hear is
[Music]
it says hugo hall is jimmy's real father
jimmy is
when you said you had to tell jimmy the
truth does that have something to do
with what you said about jimmy's birth
certificate
[Music]
for two years i should have stopped it
earlier
yeah yeah
is that in the basement it looked like
it was in the basement
i think that was in the basement i think
so
oh 96 yeah this is probably gonna be the
last step here
hugh i think that was in the basement
i'm pretty sure
that was almost 99 100
definitely sure that was in the basement
[ __ ] hugo
hugo come on oh god what the hell
oh oh that's not good
uh that's yeah it's not good
okay no i thought it was that one i
thought i thought it might have been but
apparently not but
oh oh oh uh in here ah i see
okay that sounds like over here oh
[Applause]
no
okay fair i'd be unfair i i see nothing
wrong with that
except for the everything prior to the
start of the bat swinging
i still can't open it okay um
is it rose is rose
gross
[Applause]
i saw you with a wooden bat attacking
someone
who was it
hugo i buried him down there in concrete
in a secret room damn i should have done
it
that's uh you him know too
long yeah but it was my fault i
[Music]
it made it thought i couldn't accept
what i'd done
i couldn't live with myself oh
oh oh
does this have something to do with like
an item that i have a long long time ago
oh god i'm just gonna cry i don't know
where
where can i scry here can i scribe in
here
ah i probably gotta go upstairs
okay pouring liquid on
some kind of a bear well okay lg
okay um it wasn't the diazepam maybe it
was like the turpentine
thing when you said you couldn't live
with yourself
does that have something to do with what
you said about the turpentine and
lighter
i
[Music]
i don't think that's what you should oh
oh no oh no oh
no oh oh
no oh no
no no no a story a hundred percent
complete um
something about that i'm still here
i don't feel 100 complain after all this
i feel
i feel lesser less than a hundred
percent
if i'm going to be perfectly honest here
well good great
maybe it's not what i imagine it is
maybe it's not
maybe she didn't light herself on fire
maybe that's not what the deal
is
[Music]
everything seems fine here nothing to
worry about
okay i think actually this goes this way
and curves around
oh hey bud what are you doing there you
get your ass out of here you get your
ass out of here
you get your ass out you get your ass
out before i put your ass in if you know
what i'm talking about
you know what i'm saying guys you know
what i'm saying
you know what i'm talking about you
better
okay that's scary
idiot all right just gonna let him go
because i think there's more room that
way loser
okay let's go we'll get out of here get
out of my way
heal this one yeah
i also laugh ridiculously
okay here we go oh no here oh
right there
[Music]
is it rose
i saw you you were on fire what happened
if i hadn't done it myself
okay how do i do that
how do i do that
i call this the hotel of poor decisions
um i better ask jimmy
maybe i know hugo is your father jimmy
i found your birth certificate and i
know rose tried to kill him
but he failed didn't he
then where is he now
well why don't you come and meet him
okay
we have such a close personal connection
you and i
completed a rose store all right where
to buddy
hey just show me show me the way
hello you there pal
hey come on don't be shy now where are
you off to
where you run away to buddy hey come
here buddy
i'm guessing it might be in the basement
are you trying to lead me to the
basement
is that what you're doing
i'm just under assumptions that in that
room down there where uh
old hugster might be buried you know
where's my friends i forgot all my
friends are kidnapped by you
huges you could uh
you know let him go or something
well that sounds nice
[Music]
jazzy oh that's different
marowski bam got me my friends macbooks
[Music]
to oh brain
mother's little secrets
she mixed the concrete herself you know
and poured it over his life
you see hugo was just one of us
just another log of the fire
he burned out that the fire
has been burning down the halls for
centuries
clearing the way lighting
i'm young and strong and rich you can't
that's great
hey what's up oh am i running away my ex
oh
no
oh i have five friends to rescue
oh okay
oh god what the hell
wait wait a minute hold on a second
what what
your game will save here for the last
time
okay you now have to risk your you
rescue your friends but if jimmy catches
you it's game oh
god oh my god
oh my god okay what are the keys that i
found 111 one
okay 111 110 121 okay 111 110
111 and 110 are over there and 121's on
the other side okay
111 110 uh no
11 110 okay it's fine okay what's the
number is this
106. 110 111 easy easy easy
peasy uh no this way
no i'm not is this one here we go yeah
okay okay okay sorry sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry oh 111.
okay if maybe my friend could help me
you know oh hey bud
how are you doing pal i know it's been a
while
i could have deadlocked it
i don't think he's out there
i think i can go straight across oh
send friend out oh
i don't like the ticking clock ticking
clock is very unpleasant
okay i'm gonna take my freaking time
with this
all right i'm assuming it's okay now to
send up
might be wrong can i save
maybe begin a game first oh god no
screw that okay go ahead as quickly as
you can
good luck
okay seems okay i i hope
i don't know
110.
hey bud hey how you doing friend pal
yeah yeah yeah i ain't gonna be eager
i am patient okay
get to the stairs as quickly as you can
the stairs
why don't we just go as a group why
don't we go as a group
there were three of us right here it's
pretty good odds
pretty good
okay that was pretty far
damn it just in case i'm going right in
the bathroom
yep yep yep yep easy
there's no way there's no way there's no
way
there's no way he ain't got me there's
no way
what's up [ __ ] you don't know i'm here
okay okay
we're fine i don't like that i don't
like that
i don't like that at all i don't like
that none
okay but i'm gonna do the shouting trick
i'm gonna do the shout trick
and i'm actually let's see
let me just see what we're dealing with
here
let me make sure he's not just about to
pop up again
[Music]
okay it's fine okay so what i have is i
have room 121
205 and 303 so
121 205 303. i'm gonna do the door trick
it's i know it works just i know it
works hey
hey my
uh he was pretty far it might have been
okay oddly enough
oh damn it but this is okay i know this
works
i'ma let him go by and i'm gonna run
like the wind
i may not get to where i need to go but
if i'm fast enough he shouldn't be
you know behind me that close so it
should be okay i'm getting to 121.
okay he's taking a while he must have
been like
all the way on the other side yeah
it's probably a very good opportunity
for me to have just gone
nah but this is fine
okay i'm going for it here we go
okay 121 we need to cross the elevators
i know we got to go on the other side of
the elevators this way this way this way
do not go
okay we're going straight over straight
over straight over straight over
straight over straight over 121 121 121
121 121 i don't remember where
specifically 121 is
uh oh god i'm probably going the wrong
way what is this
120 oh [ __ ] oh god damn it
i passed it god damn it [ __ ]
okay but i think i must have been way
ahead of him
i had to have been so far ahead of him
oh god no not like this oh
[ __ ] god damn it oh frick
oh frick oh he's so gonna get me
oh my god
oh my god oh my god i'm dead i'm dead
i'm dead i'm dead i know i'm dead i know
i'm dead
god damn it oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] we're still alive holy [ __ ]
which way did he go
okay he's real close he hasn't gone far
at all
i'm just gonna wait patiently i'm in no
hurry i am in no rush
i'm just letting him go by there okay
i'm gonna go
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay 121 to the
right
down the way a little bit this way
120 and this would be 121.
no what the hell where's 121
oh my god screw this oh screw this
oh my god is this 121 yes oh god no ah
frick
frick frick frick frick
come on come on come on come on come on
i'm gonna deadbold it before i even look
through the eyehole even if he's like
there
i'm gonna deadbold it first because i'm
in no hurry
safety forced safety forced
okay i'm gonna deadbold it i'm a
deadbolt 121 deadbolt oh i can't
goddamn
okay now the only thing is i don't
have any goddamn clue of where i need to
go to get back
good thing uh yeah good thing good thing
good thing anything i think i go left
because if he only went to the right a
little bit that means that's a dead end
over there
left and then i think a right and then
straight and then right
left right straight right elevator
second floor okay get to the elevator as
quickly as you can
just two more that's it just two more
you know two more easy peasy
easy squeeze me 205 303
no problem no probs no probs
no probs you know
that's pretty far away let me
you're right okay
we're fine we're good we're good we're
good we're good we're good
that scared me for a second but i was
almost positive
come on come on come back come on we
gotta go okay
was it two it was 205 205.
i should just be able to go straight to
it the first floor is definitely the
hardest one because you had to go around
there's no way that he's up here already
so i can go straight to 205
which way which way god damn it which
way that's 206 isn't it
okay so is the other way okay
to a five to one
okay yeah the problem with 205 is that
it's definitely at the end of the hall
so
205 here we go 205 205.
hello friend yes hello
okay so i remember this time it's out
and then
i take a left so i take a left here and
then i kind of wiggle and then left
that's what it is i know it's what it is
hey bud
how you doing good to see you just
checking just waiting
i can probably get one door down and
then do the door trick and then sprint
for it
okay should be fun get to the stairs as
quickly as you can as quickly as you can
last friend i can do this 303 303 is the
winner
three or three and i'm out of here
hot spaghetti i'm done three or three
okay he's far i needed to hear the voice
because that means to me that he's not
lurking around a corner because if he
was just lurking around the corner
don't trust him if i can hear
floorboards creaking i'm assuming that
means he's close enough to get me
i'm gonna go for it i think i at least i
get to maybe 201.
uh
okay i'm gonna get in here
okay 201 that's good if i just play
hopscotch i'm fine with that
i'm fine with hopscotch i like hopscotch
i think hopscotch is a fun game
uh okay so this time
he might keep going yeah he's gonna keep
going okay perfect
and then i just go and i'm gonna go and
it's a left turn it's a i go
right here and then left straight and
then this way
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes go go go
faster faster faster now now now three
three three go go go go
okay three or three
okay last one last one if i play my
cards right i go home happy
303 this way okay three or three this
way
okay which way was three or three oh
what is this
what are you 301 no not that one okay
what are you 302 perfect
seems like it's synchronous no god damn
it
god damn it oh my god oh my god do not
do this to
for the me of all that i
love
okay friend last friend can you help me
beat this guy up
can we all beat this guy up like
beat him up like beat him up like just
really pile drive him he's there i know
he's there
okay i'm not going to send her out now
[Music]
i really don't know if it matters if i
send them out when he's nearby
but i'm not gonna risk anything at this
point
okay go on friend as quickly as you can
as quickly as you can
okay and then we wait and then we leave
and then we're out of here and then
all's good
what was that scream
i'll find the exit and get out okay what
was the scream about
hopefully that was fine i'm so nervous
because
i'm i'm all done i just got to go to the
ground floor
and get out that's pretty much it
that's all i gotta do
there is so what i can do
is i can call for him and then i can
do the trick because i'm in room 303 i
think i'm one ahead
of the rooms i'm almost positive i am
now i'm doubting it
and in doing so i can do the sprint
trick that i always do
it's worked every time there's no reason
why it wouldn't work this time
i'm gonna do it
i'm here
okay as soon as he leaves that way
i go out it's a rut it's i turn
right from the door i go right yeah
okay let's [ __ ] do it let's do it
let's do it let's make it happen no time
to mess around here we go
here we go here we go last one
come on come on come on here we go here
we go this way yes
yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes yes straight this way
yes oh my god i'm so stressed i've never
been more stressed in my life
oh my god go down no no
oh my god are you kidding me
what is happening holy [ __ ] oh my god
oh my god oh my god
that was terrifying
ah then i just leave
right
where did my friends all leave without
me is the question or are they all there
i don't know oh
so do i go out these doors or no no
okay there was something about the skri
said this way i don't know what that
is i don't have any of these keys how am
i gonna
oh oh whoa
[Applause]
[Music]
later
i'm not there anymore
[Music]
stop stop stop stop stop it
why do you keep making me do these
things
please just stop
please just stop it stop it
[Music]
you're always going to do it jimmy
i'm in charge not you
i'm in charge
[Music]
the hell is that
in each of us is another whom we do not
know well that's profound and
probably meaningless anyway that is
oh he speaks to us in dreams oh okay
and tells us how differently he sees us
from the way we see ourselves
okay that's better much better okay carl
oh hello
you can see them
[Music]
at dead of night oh
all right
[Music]
spooky
all right i love that i love that
i loved this game just
a fantastic experience there were some
times where it was like
you know frustrating with the amount of
uh running away you had to do with
jimmy but honestly in the last portion
having to run away from him perfectly
and not get caught or else you lose the
game
i the stakes were very high and i would
have been very upset if i had
you know died then but by the time i got
to there i had learned enough about how
to deal with them like i'd learned some
tricks and i'd been able to try things
out so honestly i can't fault it for
that
that was still very good
oh man i enjoyed that a lot
a lot more than i thought i would enjoy
that was just really a
great experience you know what i mean
that was just fun
that was legitimately fun i love the the
uniqueness of it
i haven't seen a game like that i've
seen some games that have full motion
video
i haven't seen one that's like that
involved blending 3d and 2d together
like that and i'm sure there have been
but you know
i just really really like that fantastic
i don't know if there's a true ending
but i really hope that there's a sequel
to this game
because this was really well done i hope
they make another one that's like this
but expand it even farther maybe get a
better bald cap
but other than that great definitely
support this game play for yourself
maybe there's some secrets that i
haven't seen
let's see what game stats uh 100
attack you ten times yeah you learned
the hotel secrets you rescued all your
friends hey
okay looks like i did it looks like i
did it
nothing that seems to be missing here so
that's good thank you everybody so much
for watching if you've got other horror
games like this that you want me to play
let me know down in the comments below
thank you and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye